so there was a seventeen-year-old from
Australia who has now become a new Isis
spokesman this is crazy there's been
this fascination with Westerners that
are becoming spokesmen for Isis and
joining the movement so we've got some
video this message I delivered to you
the people of America I deliver this
message to you the people of Britain and
I deliver this message to you especially
the people of Australia and I say this
about your coalition you threaten us
with this coalition of countries bring
every nation that you wish to us bring
every nation that you want to come and
fight us it means nothing to us whether
it's 50 nations or 50,000 nations it
means nothing to us
bring your planes bring everything you
want to us because you will not harm us
why because we have a large ZOA gel and
this is something that you do not have
to the leaders to Obama the Tony ever I
say this these weapons that we have
these soldiers we will not stop fighting
we will not put down our weapons until
we reach your lands until we take the
head of every tyrant and until the black
flag is flying high in every single land
until we put the Black Flag on top of
Buckingham Palace art we put the black
flag on top of the White House we will
not stop and we will keep on fighting
and we will fight you and we will defeat
you bid me light Allah that Allah slow
okay so ABC News is reporting that he is
Abdullah El Muir who went missing from
West Sydney about four months ago I mean
he's got a crew he's got a posse they're
into what he's saying um black flag on
top of Buckingham Palace and the White
House so again we were just talking
about the UH propaganda element of this
whole thing how fearful should we be
about these be like that is kinda scary
room for these people and knowing that
he's coming from the West and leading
this thing I never liked pep rallies up
I will say that I think that the the
propaganda war something that we could
be waging better at least I think that
it is become so easy to sort of portray
the West in America is the Great Satan
or whatever
and it might help us to maybe counteract
that to some extent and you know not
make it so easy for these guys to
recruit you know these kind of wide-eyed
yet easily impressionable young people
uh you know I'm a big fan of uh you know
the Marshall Plan you know I'm all about
let's show up with butter and not just
guns yeah and I think that there that
there are things we could be doing the
Middle East to sort of rebrand the
United States as the people who are
constantly putting boots on sacred soil
right so I'm with you now I use do a bit
about this my stand back like give these
people PlayStation and they might have
something else to do as opposed to
bombing them nobody has at their house
drop on them and then thinks you know I
love these guys um does this sort of
show how desperate Isis is in a way that
they keep pushing this stuff out like
that the fear factor with that thing is
bigger than what actually maybe they're
accomplishing on the ground I mean I
think it definitely like makes people
uncomfortable the idea that you know
Nationals with foreign passports could
be converted to this like Jesus camp for
psychopaths and you know are out there
like claim you know saying these things
I think it's a it's definitely a scary
thing you know they're they're preying
on these like desperate people you know
and they're just indoctrinating I think
it's it's it's really terrifying so what
is desperate about this cuz I'm
fascinated by this thing where these
Westerners and often a lot of the ones
especially from England their their
middle class some of them are upper
middle class some of them from France
also uh so they're not that desperate in
the way we think of desperate like that
they're destitute or homeless and
nowhere else to turn a lot of them are
middle-class people kids
I mean sixteen seventeen year old so
what is it about this thing that's
appealing to a seventeen year old girl
for Jesus and work come on now and that
the you know fanaticism knows no
socio-economic level and so if you have
people who are dissatisfied with their
life or their parents or whatever and
you know you can it's it's easy to push
them into any kind of movement that
claims to have all the answers that
makes them feel important uh and it just
so happens that the one of these guys
have lives on too is Isis right and uh
that's what's happening right now me III
think that you you see similar
activities from similar you disaffected
youth you know in all kinds of places
just the other ones aren't carrying guns
and posting videos on YouTube yeah I
guess maybe at sixteen seventeen I was
thinking more about sex and drugs and
video games and basketball that I don't
know that something like this where they
would have taken all those things away
from me would have appealed to me so I
don't know why that's the part that I'm
have like I get your point but that's
the part I can't really get around so
what appeals to these guys about not
having these freedoms that particually a
lot of upper-middle class I think that
for a lot of people who have been raised
in you know relative comfort and luxury
if you can sell them on a UH a sort of
radical fundamentalist fill-in-the-blank
religious path then that's that that's a
what means of rebellion and that's all
my cushy stuff is terrible and how dare
you give this to me parents and you know
that that's as much of a weapons
anything else
I guess I'm Pro cushy stuff I feel like
here your throat they were all broken oh
gosh no one joining Isis around using my
first thought when I watch the video was
that it was Jonah from Tonga you know
the Chris life Politico I mean the same
accent same disenfranchised Philly we
could learn a lot from that show get
this guy a rap contract I think I said
in there um do you think that these
people that go that leave countries like
Australia France in the US and Britain
everything should be allowed to come
back that's the debate right now in
Congress although Congress is really
working but that seems to be a debate
right now should we allow these people
to leave and then come back in the
country
I don't think into that uh crazy to say
no if you go fight for Isis you have to
give up your pass I think I think we
said carry from homeland to turn them
and to get they become double agents yet
otherwise you know forget it we would
you let these people back in I mean that
all these countries are debating this
should these people be allowed to come
back I don't even see how that's a
debate
think that if if there's like evidence
they've bought into a psychopathic uh
murderous terrorist ideology like you
know like ISIL I think not passport
revoked if you've been the head of your
own government uh then I'd say pretty
much that's you've thrown your passport
on the ground and spit on it that's it's
kind of our right wing nut bags here on
the Rubin report this week